hallo meine lieben freunde wie spielen
heute in hänsel los
da hat man stift als nase und muss auch
so einen dingen sachen drauf zeichnen
und die andere person muss erraten
zeigen schon die komplette erklärung das
hier ist der erste begriff den ich jetzt
mal werde wo man gottes das schwert aber
etwas schwer was soll ich sagen ich weiß
nicht ob die leute das erkennen können
ja aber was sind die höhe die ta nea
die schweiz
ja
dann einfach nichts bekannt im video
dieses waren wichtig jetzt mal ist
zwiebeln 1 das ist die sonne nein
natürlich ist dass die sonne rein
riesenrad nein
wie heißt diese ventilator dinger die
namen weltklima strom betrat das ist
eine kappe sonnenblume das ist das
ergebnis stimmt mal eine art ist das
nettop ist ein löwenzahn
[Musik]
das hier ist mein erstes wort
heraus doch bisschen wild aus
der auto bild denn das wort aber ich
wollte die rabatte mal
das jetzt mein nächstes wortwahl das
brot den fernseher ein radio das ist der
fernseher dann ist es die stoßwellen
frequenz maschine helfen trostberg mit
dem ding poster
stretcher thomas das ist das ist doch
das ist ein küchengerät
hey was ist das monster schreibtisch im
gehege
kuchen das ist eine schwarze reaktor 3
sei hier störte
die zeitung
kein wunder dass sich der koch
dieses wort im osten als nächstes
erwarten
ich sagte dass ich wohl die maschine nee
nee nee
maschine nach weiter
[Musik]
gerade mit den koffern
menge hier um mein gott nein ich gebe
dir den weg so blöd das
soll deutschland flagge soll
so von thomas baum gefallen oder was
[Musik]
tomate zwiebel das ist ziemlich nein das
sonst so komisch wurde ich
bin ich das dann ist es gut nein die
million ist der bösewicht
das ist mein nächstes wort
[Musik]
herr sich
medien
das hier ist jetzt mein nächstes war
hosenträger ist auf jeden fall ist hat
vier beine keine ahnung warum immer
dementiert
ja
das hilft ein trick die schönes fährt
das ist mein erstes wort ein auto
das ist nur wo du kannst hätten die ich
weiß doch was ich hier hat man nun
könnte das ist alles was ich den roman
das sind ganz große sache aber
[Musik]
zeit vorbei
wo das sind sterne
das ist
okay das jetzt mein nächstes wort
fertig
im quadrat
[Musik]
da waren tosti gedacht die oben wissen
nein das ist ein stück von mir
[Musik]
das ist mein nächstes
worten
[Musik]
ich bin fertig eigentlich
ist jetzt unter co tja
das ist jetzt mein nächstes war thaddeus
attacke das ist nicht geklappt sagt prof
das punkt das ist ein super oma lotte
sieht es genauso aus wie klopapier frau
körperlich
und
nicht auslaufen sodass hier ist auf
jeden fall als hätte
das ist mein nächstes wort
[Musik]
dinosaurier hilfe
krokodil
sowohl was das für tino ist
nein littlefoot war als die gibt keinen
sinn und david thewlis aus dem film was
ist das von
dinosaurier sex was
dann terex
dinosaurier rex
das ist mein nächstes wort geben landtag
boden bodenwerder antenne flagge
golfplatz golfer
golfschläger
um schlägst du dich jetzt
das hier ist mein letztes wort ist mir
dann die straße
welt äquator der erde
erklärt
was ist das hier eine blume das ist ein
stück scheiße aber du musst dir das
große ganze
[Musik]
der scheiße gelaufen feld
ich habe erst einmal auf dem feld
gepackt
nein ich mal nah am wasser
organisationssystem hier sind die rohre
hier ist die scheiße hier fließt der
piste durch jetzt zeige ich glaube das
ist unter der erde ist
das mein letztes wort das er auf jeden
fall vier reifen die aus tätig zwiebeln
aber ich denke dass ein auto ist es
könnte polizeiauto taxi
er stellte sich das heute wie das alexa
beende meine lieben freunde wenn euch
hänseln los mit mir und taten spaltet
das kann einen daumen hoch und in dem
video hielt da aber der knall und klickt
auf die glocken weitere videos nicht zu
verpassen auf einem zwei kanal ist
soeben ein anderes video welt gegangen
das könnt euch angucken den ihr hier auf
pekings kopf oder ihr könnt meinen kanal
abonnieren in dem ihr hier auf meinem
kopf klickt das hier ist ein flexi
gewesen das ist schön das geht so
ein taxi fährt normalerweise nicht auf
zwiebeln
taxiert doch eigentlich fenster du warst
so schnell